WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS CADILLAC XLR
FOR ABOUT, UH, 6 MILES.
OBVIOUS D.U.I.
SWERVING ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
OH, LOOK AT THAT.
[CAR DOOR SLAMS]
SIR?
MISS?
HOW YOU DOING TONIGHT, MA'AM?
HOW YOU DOING TONIGHT?
CAN YOU ROLL THE WINDOW
DOWN?
I'M STUCK!
ARE YOU TRYING--
DID YOU HAVE ANY
DRUGS OR ALCOHOL
TONIGHT, MA'AM?
I CAN'T HEAR YOU!
YES, YOU CAN,
BECAUSE I CAN HEAR YOU.
SO YOU CAN OBVIOUSLY
HEAR ME.
NO, I CAN'T.
TRAVIS? IT'S, UH,
BUNNY HERNANDEZ.
[DOOR DINGING]
SHUT UP!
THAT'S THE
MAYOR'S WIFE.
IT'S THE MAYOR'S WIFE.
AH, [BLEEP].
OK, YOU GOOD?
YOU GOOD?
WHERE'S MY HUSBAND?
YOU THINK YOU CAN DRIVE?
ARE YOU MY HUSBAND?
NO, NO, NO.
MRS. HERNANDEZ--
THAT'S OK.
SHE'S FULL OF FUN.
I GOTTA GO
TO TAHOE.
UH...
[BLEEP]
WHOA!
UNH! [BLEEP]
BUNNY? YOU'RE
MARRIED TO A VERY
POWERFUL MAN.
VERY POWERFUL.
HE STINKS.
HE IS OUR BOSS.
HE'S A MEXICAN.
HE IS A LATINO
GENTLEMAN,
BUT HE IS STILL
OUR BOSS.
YOU CAME UP
A LONG WAY.
YEAH.
REMEMBER, BUNNY,
WHO USED TO DO
THE AMATEUR--YEP.
YEAH.
YEAH, THOSE THINGS?
THAT WAS REAL GOOD.
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO DO THAT ANYMORE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
YOU GOT A REAL NICE HOUSE,
YOU ARE LIKE--
GOT A NICE, NEW CADILLAC,
I GOT A BABY COMING.
THEY KEYS WENT UP
HER BOTTOM CRACK.
LET'S JUST LEAVE HER HERE.
OH, YEAH!
I GOTTA TAKE A PISS.
NO--OK.
SHE'S POOPIN'.
OH, I'M MAKING
A MESS.
TAKE--TAKE YOUR BRIT--
YOUR DRAWERS OFF.
NO RUSH.
DID YOU TAKE YOUR PANTIES OFF?
I DON'T KNOW.
NOT WEARING ANY.
OK.
ALL RIGHT.
I GOTTA GO.
WE'RE JUST GONNA
ESCORT YOU TO TAHOE.
OW!
OH, CRAP.
IT'S ONLY ABOUT
6 MILES.
OK, IN WE GO.
OK.
IN WE GO,
IN WE GO.
NOW, BUNNY--
BUNNY?
HEY, BUNNY?
A NICE LADY DOESN'T
[BLEEP] HERSELF
IN THE BACK SEAT.
BUNNY?
WHERE AM I?
WOULD PRINCESS DIANA
BE [BLEEP] HERSELF
IN THE BACK SEAT?
NO.
AND YOU'RE OUR
PRINCESS DI.